And that sort of,
that's where the West is powerful.
I would say like we have a really well
developed mythology of the exploratory
hero,
but where we're not so well developed is
the second part because in the second
part of the classic Hero's story,
you're supposed to come back and
communicate about what you found and so
there's a individual exploration element
and then there's a communicate and
update the culture element and both of
those are equally important and it's
something that we don't do well.
We don't have much respect for tradition
in the west and it's a really,
really big problem because the ethical
responsibility of a human being is to
take the dead culture so that's the dead
father or the Dad God,
and to revivify it with attention and
communication and you've failed to do
that.
Then everything disappears.
And we we are failing to do that.
We're leaving it all behind instead.
It's not a good idea.
You know,
if the old gods die,
as Nietzsche said,
they had new gods swoop in very rapidly,
and if you think the old guard was bad,
you wait until the new gods get ahold of
you.
So while we saw what happened in the
20th century,
right,
with all the ideologies that sprang up
in the absence of classical religious
belief,
it's like,
okay,
you're not so thrilled with Catholicism.
If you think about that is,
you know,
the fundamental tradition of the West,
with the witch burnings and the
inquisition and all that,
it's like,
yeah,
well get a load of the Nazis and then
see what you think.
So,
or the communists for that matter.
It's like from bad to worse in an
unimaginable way,
you know,
so,
and it's partly because those archaic
systems,
those are religious systems,
they weren't ideologies.
There are a whole different class of
thing and we don't understand them very
well and it's not good because you
cannot live without understanding them.
You don't know who you are.
And then you fall prey to weird mental
diseases like nihilism.
That's one.
Another one is ideological possession.
So you become a totalitarian or an
analyst and that's a bad outcome and you
might think,
well,
what's the alternative?
Well,
you know what happens in Pinocchio,
right?
You've watched Pinocchio.
Okay.
I often show up in oak you to this
class,
but I don't know if I'm going to do that
this year.
But anyways,
but now he's a puppet marionette.
Someone else's pulling his strings has,
it wouldn't head.
He's not very bright.
He hasn't banged around the world at
all.
He's not a good father.
The old Japan who really would rather
that he was a real boy,
right?
A real person.
So he's the kind of father that wants to
produce an individual and not a slave.
So.
And that's why,
you know,
in his workshop it's all friendly and
there's a nice fire and he's making toys
and there's lots of music.
It's like go Japan.
Oh,
he's a good guy.
So it makes this little puppet and he
sends them out in the world,
says,
go be a real boy.
Well,
Pinocchio runs into a whole class of
different obstacles.
One is evil,
right?
That's the,
uh,
that's the coachman.
And the Italian stereotype guy who makes
him a dancing puppets celebrity,
which I think is pretty funny.
I mean that's really prescient,
you know,
because you might think,
well,
what's the goal of your typical bone
headed?
You know,
mid adolescent in North America.
It's like unearned celebrity.
Well that's exactly what Pinocchio goes
for first and that doesn't work out so
well because he ends up with slave.
And then the next thing that happens is
he capitalizes on the fact that he's
vulnerable and pretends he's sick and
goes off for a vacation under the
direction of the coachman who's
basically Satan in disguise and it goes
out to treasure island,
pleasure island,
and meets all the delinquent.
So we're just like Nazis.
And it turns out that in fact,
the whole ploy is to enslave everyone to
deprive them of their voice.
That's the donkey's brain.
And to make them into slaves pretty damn
horrifying.
And that was,
that movie came out about the same time
that the Nazis were really grasping
power in,
in central Europe.
It's like they got it exactly right.
Here's what's really going on behind the
scenes.
So.
And then what happens?
Well,
Pinocchio turns halfway into a brain
donkey because you know,
he's gone off the path and in order to
get back on it,
he tries to go home,
but it's too late.
He's grown up.
You can't go home.
He's not a kid anymore.
Goes home and dad,
isn't there surprise,
surprise,
because once you grow up and you go
home,
dad isn't there.
It's just another human being.
So then what happens?
Well then he has to go into the ocean.
Now that's particularly weird,
right?
It's like there he is,
half donkey.
He's a puppet.
The dove comes down and drops him a
message from God.
It's like the Holy Spirit descending,
except it's actually from the blue fairy
weirdly enough.
And the message says,
you have to go to the deepest part of
the ocean and rescue your father.
It's like,
yeah,
that is what you have to do.
If you don't want to be a bloody puppet
donkey,
you have to go down into the depths and
find your dead father and you have to
revivify him.
And that's what happened.
So Pinocchio goes way down there to the
deepest depths and finds monster who's a
monster.
So terrible that the fish swim away just
at the sound of his voice,
just like,
what's his name?
Uh,
he who,
who,
you shall not be named Voldemort,
right?
You can't even say his damn name.
Same with monster.
Put Ohio goes down there.
It goes into the whale.
What happens?
Japan?
Oh,
says there's no getting out with this.
There's no getting out of this.
We just have to sit here and Cook Fish
and Pinocchio Thinks Cook.
And then he starts breaking up all the
chairs and everything and his father
freaking out.
It's like,
what are you doing?
Breaking all these chairs?
What are we going to sit on?
And then Pinocchio Lights them on fire.
He's a master of fire.
It's a shamonic ritual,
but he is a master of fire.
That's what human being as he.
He gets everything burning.
Of course,
Jupiter pedals all freaked out about
that because what are they going to sit
on?
An Pinocchio?
Thanks.
Who Cares about setting?
We're going to solve the problem once
and for all.
And so then the whale turns into a fire
breathing driving,
which is pretty damn weird thing for a
whale to do.
Half Pinocchio,
he lived,
washes up on shore dead,
but he saves his father.
Then at the very end of the movie,
he's lying on his bed,
all drowned.
They're all like having a show.
He's a dead pop it now.
It's like,
do you want to be alive?
Popular?
A dead puppet.
Well,
maybe the dead puppet is better than the
life puppet.
It depends on where you're going.
So then he's on the bed,
the blue fairy comes down and says,
well,
you've been honest and courageous.
Bang.
Now you're real.
You know?
And then they have a little party and
that's,
that's just exactly right.
Exactly right.
So that's how.
That's part of the hero mythology is the
rescuing of the father after rescue the
father.
Because otherwise you're a corpse.
Like you're a historical creature.
You're a cultural creature.
You're a,
you cannot live without your culture.
You think you can,
but you can't.
It disappears in and you don't even
look.
I'll give you an example in the
Mesopotamian creation myth,
which I'm going to tell you about next
week,
one of the things that happens is that
the first round of gods,
so they're like primordial forces.
They're pretty damn careless and they
killed their father and they make this
place to live on his corpse.
Okay?
That's where we live.
We live on the corpse of our ancestors
because we live in this society.
It's dad,
it's the product of dead people,
so he's gotten his ged element,
but we're living on it.
Okay?
There are very careless.
They kill it.
They sold it,
they leave,
render it completely dead.
Well,
what happens is tire Matt,
who's the mother of chaos,
she comes flooding back and she thinks,
oh,
you killed the thing that protects you.
You just wait to see what happens and
that's exactly.
Yet you killed the thing that structures
you.
You will know it.
It's like niches,
prediction from the death of God.
It's like you killed this.
You think are.
It doesn't make any difference.
It's like,
ha,
wrong.
It's like the striders protecting the
hobbits.
You get rid of that thing that protects
you in chaos,
comes flooding in and you like.
You have no idea what's possible.
We do though,
because we lived through the 20th
century,
we know exactly what's possible.
You know,
hundreds of millions of unnecessary
deaths.
That's what's possible.
We're lucky we didn't blow the whole
damn thing up,
so when we still could,
so people pursuing their dead
etiologies.
You don't rescue the dead father.
You're the puppet of death.
That's what you are.
On that cheery note.